[Musik]
[Applaus]
ein neuer blog guten morgen liebe sorgen
es ist zehn uhr 30 und ich habe fertig
haben fünf minuten einen corner und
google mit sich denkt in fünf minuten
jetzt habe ich jetzt so wirklich
eigentlich noch nie aber wenn hat die
sind nicht mit am stand sind wenn ich da
auf jeden fall haben bock darauf dass am
dienstag oder mittwoch anhalt
dementsprechend zu machen eine ewigkeit
später nachdem ich jetzt gerade in call
mit einer von youtube hatte hat mich
jetzt im angriff will damit sagen was
sagen alles klar ich muss erst das ist
tatsächlich gar nicht mal so scheint nur
wenige minuten später
meine mutter hat mit gartens partners
geschickt weil wir zusammen an einem
zweiten buch schreiben werden und sie
hat am ende eigentlich tag aber was die
am ende gesagt hat gar nicht wie ich
gesagt dass ich heute machen wollte und
war vielleicht dass man hier auch danach
noch
klavier lernen danach reichte markt von
heute abend in apparate clubs
wahrscheinlich an die firma gelesen aber
das kommt an wenn ich bestelle ich meine
kamera übrigens genau dorthin und
emotionen besonders stativ
das weiß ich heute abend machen
[Musik]
jetzt hab ich auch unseren coolen dran
vorbei gehen schon gemacht
ich werde jetzt ein bisschen der kamera
ab hat eine gerät
die akkus in der kamera freunde das web
warum regnet auf einmal
wir haben unsere regeln wir die
richtigen max und ich wollten eigentlich
nur fussball challenge heute machen
dabei hat sich das bei dem wetter jetzt
wohl erledigt es hat aufgehört zu regnen
max übrigens bevor du gehst
ich hatte im blog öffentlich machen da
meine freundin ist jetzt die frage mich
heiraten möchte nein als auch manchmal
hatte ich ja auch noch
[Musik]
wir kommen zu früh zu sagen haben essen
während ich jetzt mein video für heute
aufnehmen
blende ich euch jetzt einfach noch mal
ein paar szenen einen die ich noch
gefilmt hatte als ich in berlin war
letzte woche bei der sommerparty
sportstudio 71 hatte ich noch ein paar
sachen gefilmt die ja ich irgendwie
bisher noch nicht gezeigt habe also film
gerade megacool wir sind ja gerade bei
der studio 71 in berlin und ich habe
gerade einfach meinen größten verein
getroffen als faktor für die richtige
antwort
dafür brauchen wir nicht
er ist chef aller zeiten oder welcher
die kabine
auf titeljagd betrieben und damit auch
nicht was ist denn die gestik tower und
das heißt jetzt hallo
wahrscheinlich sind deine eltern nicht
zufrieden mit euch sicher dass es
frankfurt ist oder ist es eher dresden
können beim nächsten rastplatz
vorausfahren eher weniger ich glaube der
ist kaputt zwanziger partner getrunken
wird sonst ihren zettel
ich bin kleiner in die kinos
[Musik]
da seid ihr ja wieder
ich beobachte meine waschmaschine das
war schon
eigentlich bin ich schon raus man es tut
mir leid falls ist jetzt ein bisschen
komisch war noch ein paar alte szenen
aus berlin von vor einer woche hier im
blog zu sehen aber ich habe mir gedacht
gesehen habe ich in berlin aufgenommen
aber ohne irgendwie intro zu drehen aber
es ist auch schade gewesen dass einfach
alles viel waschen und habe ich werde
einfach gedacht er packe ich jetzt
einfach noch mal hier in den block 3
nach übrigens falls ihr euch fragt wieso
ich jetzt mal mit dieser dslr blogge das
ist nicht falsch jetzt irgendwie die
beste qualität hier meine blogs haben
will
hier kennt mich qualität ist das
scheißegal sondern wirklich einfach weil
die sony kamera mit der ich sonst nur
blogger die kleine konnten schreiben
dies gerade hier drin
die werde ich jetzt gleich zurück zu
sorgen die sendung dann gucke ich mal
dass das ding vielleicht reparieren
können aber hinsichtlich der kamera
sache kann ich jetzt erstmal nur
abwarten ich werde jetzt aber auf jeden
fall erstmal nur frischen aber das passt
eigentlich ganz gut weil dann kann ich
nur über ein thema reden was mir sehr am
herzen liegt wieder sagen der mensch ist
das beste säugetier der welt nein es
sind die alpakas
das war das was ich sagen wollte hat
video preis jury kann ich vielleicht ein
letztes mal ein preis für beste blocker
bekommen
luca was ist jetzt eigentlich mit dem
titel das du deiner freundin einen
heiratsantrag machen wolltest ja das ist
halt nur überraschung gewesen und sie
ist jetzt gerade bei mark war sie eine
gute freundin von jana ist und sie weiß
noch gar nicht also sie denkt dass sich
nicht in köln bin deswegen ich bin ein
bisschen aufgeregt aber ich gehe jetzt
erst mal zum max und überrascht jetzt
alle was machst du in die a ich bin
jetzt hier gerade bei max und jana
angekommen
januar eigentlich gerade dies in bad orb
okay die ist gerade auf toilette was das
jetzt wird ich hoffe dass weg wissen ich
bin ich bin wirklich mit martina jetzt
schon so drei jahre oder so zusammen
deswegen ich bin mehr gespannt 1
es ist halt immer noch richtig früh
kommt man leute ich rücke wieder mal
angeschafft werden der moment gekommen
ist martina die sache ist ich habe ja
eigentlich gesagt dass ich nicht in köln
gerade die sache ist halt dass ich mit
jana und auch mit max hier
ich habe mit denen klaren entwickelt
weil du weißt martina ich liebe dich
wir haben sicher auch deshalb führt an
und haben einen plan
er fragt sie doch jetzt endlich in china
[Musik]
nein
möchtest du gewalt gebaut werden
[Musik]
gering
auch immer leute darunter sind sogar
schon die partygäste darf ja alle leute
da unten sind für dich gekommen ist das
x10 machen jetzt
[Musik]
versteckte schnell machen es ist doch
unsere flitterwochen anders geht es
nicht zuletzt kommt jetzt geh mal raus
jemanden so ich habe jetzt gerade
nochmal ihren ernstes wörtchen mit max
und jana geredet weil es sind halt
einfach jetzt unsere flitterwochen
angefangen und dann müssen sie das auch
mal akzeptiert wahrscheinlich schon
bemerkt martina eine andere haarfarbe
hat martina ja auch schon mehrere wochen
monate er ist nicht mehr in den videos
hier gesehen das wird sich jetzt
natürlich wieder ein bisschen steigern
ich habe es jetzt endlich wieder
öffentlich gemacht hier meine beziehung
was heißt beziehung nicht mehr wir sind
jetzt verheiratet bzw verlobt mehr oder
weniger werden dementsprechend bald
heiraten martina ist auf jeden fall
gerade in bad essen
ich will jetzt noch ein bisschen mit den
zweien und vielleicht bei den heute
schon verlobten und eben nur noch
zusammen diese bananen sie noch jedem
fall leicht verschimmelt aus
das tut mir leid dass ich gestern abend
nicht mehr die abort um das auto für
diesen blog gemacht habe aber wir jetzt
ja vielleicht wisst bin ich seit gestern
mit martina verlobt und da wollten wir
einfach noch die nacht so ein bisschen
nutzen außerdem habe ich hier vorne
gerade ein neues mixtape für meinen
sound profil aufgenommen als oder link
in der beschreibung mit mich sehr freuen
weil ich da sehr viel zeit ein stecker
patina ist auf jeden fall gerade duschen
ich werde jetzt hier trainieren gehen
mit max und ja das war's vom blog wenn
es euch gefallen hat last lag da und
chih
[Musik]